an não havíamos dito ao ver jorge para e
só uso por sinal eles é possível por
sinal também pessoalmente o sol é
entregue o negro do que quem falou da
questão é eles sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um vídeo e os tracks equipe falam
juntos o eudes disse
tanto assim é que estava fazendo as sete
que ministrei estojo vocês pediram pra
eu jogar eu acho que já tinha ficado
família de sete crimes um e dois e
acabou de sair há dois dias atrás que
este fato nas sete scut estreia traz sua
faça uma coisa aumenta o volume aumente
usos criptônio no fusca clube vai um
comigo julgar este fascinante que as
três fora eu vou tentar traduzir isso em
português está fazendo em cannes gênero
rock usou rápido para olhar 557 olhar
para os lados e para cima e pra baixo
olha pra baixo e dois botões bom por ser
o uso e parando e player deve ser
qualquer coisa tipo 1 e turca 715 botão
vermelho é para olhar em 2001 [ __ ]
não sei quem está por provar quem é eu
sei traseira é já o melhor do google da
ruga o contrato do chumbo turbo que o
cantor não fugirá [ __ ] no trânsito um
monstro agora é parte do traçado só
vamos falar sobre um monstro o monstro
da cara
o uso do flash eu tenho extrema em
inglês para estudar pra mim tão bons
resultados quando fez tanto de monstros
hf mostra tua cara eu tenho deputado faz
o haiti a lanterna para o jorge deu pra
eu só por ser ou seja flash lite
lanterna vai ser a nossa arma principal
nessi um monstro for para debaixo da
cama foi de 8 bits online enquanto igual
o lado da cama onde está escondido ok
então temos uma cama e supostamente
vamos ter uma porta não pode por ser nem
escutou super é muito fechado o fato não
esquece este caneco isto vamos lá
coletivo tubino pessoal eu já estarmos
no quarto vejam só
eu também tô agora ver o que está na lei
14 é ainda assim a folha estas coisas o
que já se tem um bicho que ia atrás nem
pessoal eu posso ter por esta porta pode
vir por estar mário se for assim precisa
fazer nada de fred seu também pode vir
por aqui ok e caminhoneta a cama
é possível imputar uma turma eu sabia eu
sabia que o clipe por olímpica disse
manenti muito bizarra pessoal tire da
equipe isto como unidos
eu tô a oi otávio marques [ __ ] eu é
uma represália por aí por ser uma
instituição que o eleitor né
supostamente então é muito agora está
mais rápido né na urna na porta o
cuidado com o eu ainda não li shishi não
estava rápido não tava se enganaram aqui
em outra opção que basta cada fio 80
outra vez ficará no milan
o estudo é muito grande ou uma galinha
só vai à uma da manhã e ainda não perdeu
em prática e eu sentia no jogo strong há
muito tempo mas ainda não pôde prática
porém só gosta que mantém uma bola umas
caixas inapa e música para o funil não é
mau eo pessoal não dizem muito bacana e
eu tenho que ir à música outra vez a
gente não toca muito e eu tenho certeza
que eu gostaria e o cd e é muito gostoso
tá muito bom eu sou cristo ver como é
que isto aí que há tempos pra cá não é
que está no armário e faz muito barulho
essa é minha sorte é que eu consigo ver
quando eu estava aqui perto dela lista
com se tinha falei meu esse corte é
muito grande não precisará voltar à
câmara tudo é só para conseguir voltar
para casa eu posso destacar ainda não
mexe do méxico o que foi embora a opep
só de enfrentar o ju a nossa primeira
vamos lá então um de novo para continuar
o que fiz de errado em respirar fundo e
até pessoal são de que através do nosso
curtinho muito muito giro lei vocês
percebem as referências percebem isso é
uma france klm e esta é uma referência e
eu acho que é um filme que é o de sair
mas que tem uma marionete eu acho eu
acho que este robô que já tenha
percebido mundo jogos do fight night eu
acho que sim mas que o edital e também
ou eu já penso em um armário
ae no dia que eu ficar eu acho que eu
logo deu né acho que sim só sai de manin
ainda no quadro sites a casa também tem
uma luta um paninho mark player e uma
bola de nunca sair outra vez meu outro
bicho por mário não estou namorando
estou à porta é um armário este é um
armário ou isto é que é pôr fim ou já
não sai do confuso quarta muito grande
eu não seja o que importa é a normal no
ser e eu esqueci então ligar a música
pronta assim já vai mais rápido espero
que não tenha top pride não sei se tem
capilaridade de música e espero que não
me 40 ataques tenha neste momento o time
espanhol é o demônio está no meu quarto
tem de chamar um padre eu acho que as
coisas estão cheiro a sair tenho a
sensação que os títulos não estava lá
embaixo o player parou de tocar música
eu vou tentar voltar a oi conseguiu vez
conseguiu tudo muito bom rápido rápido
rápido basta permanent e isso depois ter
que provar será que é isso vai parecer
que se ela por seu doutorado foi por ser
que eu não fui muito grande o leão foi
porventura maio conseguiu escapar disse
que conseguiu escapar duas da manhã e só
vamos lá não apuramos de canapí poemas e
campis o ecosoc escapar pessoal cansa e
escapar a primeira vez do nosso ratton
não sei que tudo o que rola em olha aí o
povo vai atrás
a cápsula calma são duas da manhã está
tudo tranqüilo supostamente tem que
aguentar até às seis né existe seguir
como faz nights não é expert que já tem
asfalto 145
aí está um painel da onu onde houve um
passo de lula que neste quarto sentir o
cheiro a enxofre estou eu sabia pra nós
por lá eu tenho que ir à caixa de música
agora voltarei pra trás agora vai entrar
pra cima os pra campanha para trás e só
depois é que falta ligada a essa
estratégia pessoal se vocês jogam isso
nós nunca jogaram e vão jogar se com
esta estratégia sigam os conselhos
tutelares teclado e vai e vai dar toda
faixa eo conseg e ele vai conseguir para
botar só tô só isso três da manhã e só
13 também é pela volta basta que vamos
ter muita calma vamos tentar olhar se
vai perceber quem vai presidir lado eu
sei que vai encantar os clientes a
emprestar não é parceira assim o jamaica
pesar na li já o cerrado ocas puxa
sempre estiveram aqui está nada no
airbus que sinto se mistura música do
cara vai prejudicar tocar porque isso é
importante a ajuda a bota pra o olho do
cerrado
lá eu já sei já sei jogar rápido eu já
não me garante também é não enganar não
cair agora vai ficar uma taxa que é
bastante amigo vamos olhar agora para
que eu não sei eu ainda não percebi como
é que chove mais de calma e não sei se é
capaz de criar ainda como é que faz isto
o o toque uma da manhã pessoal uma da
manhã eo meu twitter está ligado todo o
estúdio vocês plantam fazer não para o
twitter não me incomodo jogou no twitter
estou com vitória com zé rato aranha que
vai ter um rato gigante em casa assim
diz a mãe tem
foi má altura para fazer isso ai eu
sabia que eu estava aqui eu sabia eu
sabia a macau olha no olho e isso não só
no olho vai passar a cápsula agora usar
aquela técnica
ouvi o barulho isso eu fui embora agora
pai raptou não é isso
ninguém nem lembra que o pleito foi o
rio ainda agora volta a ficar totalmente
urológicos igreja seja sem contratar no
jazz em duas da manhã e só são duas rock
e música já fiz um rio em agora é só
tocar outra vez vamos ver se eu aguento
agora fundo ataca o tac tem uma bota
para maia não sei quem é esse não é meu
é um dom a onu
meu deus é que o espaço dele e eu não
aparece logo só aparece com um ouro
escondido pois é muito complicado ouvir
do mecão vem ouvir aqui exatamente agora
é rap música da unirio haiti agora vai
isso isso dar sul três da manhã já
aguenta aguenta o pessoal chegou a falar
em favorito vamos ajudar a curar que
conseguirá passar na fuga desses não
ajuda nada calma calma calma não vai ser
agora que em breve eu tenho certeza que
vai perceber que eu já tô seguro de que
maneira o esquema de lei maio direita
esquerda toda se inventar nac ok agora o
futuro músico muito rápido e busca agora
aguenta muito perto jacaré da [ __ ]
vagabunda
eu não consegui aguentar no rádio
agora aqui o pessoal já é a segunda vez
que consigo resistir a um ataque dela
vamos lá a música através de tóquio
antes 14 também é eu já ouvi que o jogo
viu tomando como da game boy quatro da
manhã eu não posso perder agora pessoal
eu não posso e não posso perder ninguém
vai ouvir os paciais a hidratação na
velha meu vai embora
agora é o tempo de relaxar pessoal um
sua música do rebaixamento
para mim só que tudo tão relaxado músico
meu pelve está facilitando assim isto
mesmo aí o rato foi embora e não está
ruim a chave 14 tempo não passa como é
que o tempo não passa mas só em pai isso
e ei mostra o início que caiu da cadeira
é muito alta de que num agora eu vou
esperar o próximo ataque de 15 da manhã
o curso isto supera isso não usaremos
mais tantas pena que agora vá sentir a
música premir toque toque muito rápidos
eo rap também já no segundo dia mas vai
valer até agora e lembra que o futuro já
sem cansado da maior já fugiu à tarde o
conselho agora só falta um destino já
posso escolher água vento em todas as
paredes só e rato que não consegue
agüentar eu consegui
acho que tá vendo fidel civil a games o
nã festa na casa bizarro de olhar pra
mim é mais só vamos ficar porque com
isso faz mais é quem é do estreante
dentro de um dos comentários mais longos
de doura que deixou 18 a 8